[MUSIC "BILL NYE THE SCIENCE GUY
THEME SONG"]
BILL NYE: Love that song.
Yes.
Can we use these?
Is this OK?
VIKRAM BAJAJ: I hope so.
BILL NYE: Let's hope they work.
There's a lot of
gravity up here.
I can feel it.
Look at this guy on
the picture, man.
He will mess you up.
Wow.
It's big.
It's the big picture.
Yes, Vik, greetings.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Very
nice to meet you.
So I'd like to
begin by taking you
through some really depressing
slides, if you don't mind.
I'm sorry about this.
BILL NYE: Yeah, that'd be great,
because I was really upbeat.
Let's knock that down.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Click
through these.
BILL NYE: Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So
we're very concerned
about public perceptions
of science, as are you.
And there's some really
depressing numbers.
I'm just going to go
through them rapidly.
So first of all, only
40-some percent of Americans
right now believe
that global warming
is caused by human activity.
BILL NYE: Less than
half is our problem.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Less than half.
BILL NYE: When it comes to
elections, that's a big deal.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Oh.
BILL NYE: No, it is.
That's what I'm talking about.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: And as
a consequence of that,
very few people actually
believe that this is a problem
that we'll face
in our lifetimes.
And--
BILL NYE: Oh, you'll see.
Yeah.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So--
[LAUGHTER]
BILL NYE: No, I mean,
it's a big deal.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: In the
case of human evolution,
we also have a similar problem.
Only 19% of Americans,
according to Gallup,
believe in the unfettered
human evolution
driven by natural physical laws.
There's about 30% who
believe in something called
intelligent design, and
about a constant number
who believe that
we were all created
6,000 years ago, in an instant.
And another consequence
of this is really
how it's being
taught in schools.
Here in red, you
see all the states
where there is no mention
of human evolution
in the formal school curricula.
Some mention biological
evolution, but not
human evolution, not
evolution of mankind.
And--
BILL NYE: He means humankind.
No, I mean, it's
just a new habit.
For example, my mom was a
woman, just for example.
She's right there.
It's not unusual.
No.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: But we'll ask
you about her later, actually.
So there's also a
depressing trend
to use public taxpayer
money, taxpayer dollars,
to fund creation education
in public schools
in several states, in charter
schools, in voucher schools.
And of course, there are
mainstream politicians
who don't believe
in this at all.
Now--
BILL NYE: You have the
picture of the guys--
how many of you running for
president believe in evolution?
Three of them don't.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Yes.
BILL NYE: Can you imagine--
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Three of the
four Republican governors.
BILL NYE: --if these guys
got to be in charge-- well,
they are in charge.
They're governors.
The most technically
advanced-- at least
the biggest innovations, like
Google, come out of the US.
And to have people
that don't believe
in the process of
science running the show
is just a formula for disaster.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Absolutely.
BILL NYE: It is.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So Google
is a scientific company.
We're very science
driven, quantitative.
And this is particularly
depressing to us.
Here's belief in evolution--
BILL NYE: Oh,
gosh, look at this.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: And I know that
some of your recent criticism
of pseudo science,
in general, really
is based on arguments of
economic competitiveness.
BILL NYE: For me, it is, yeah.
Like you guys-- how many of you
watch "The Science Guy" show?
AUDIENCE: [CHEERING]
BILL NYE: I love
you, man, woman.
No, so if we produce a
generation of science students
that don't believe
in science, you're
not going to have the next
Google, whatever that is.
You will not have
the next generation
of employees at Google.
Texas Instruments had to
advertise for, I guess,
engineers in Maryland,
because they were concerned--
Texas Instruments is not called
Maryland Instruments-- because
of the quality of the Maryland
school system in comparison.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Absolutely.
So hopefully, you'll
help us, you'll arm us--
BILL NYE: It's all me.
Yeah.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: with
instruments to fight this,
because our reaction
in observing this
is to be pretty depressed.
We don't know how exactly
to counteract these forces.
We hope you'll
teach us about that.
Maybe, actually, this
would be more appropriate,
considering the subject
of our conversation today.
BILL NYE: For those
of you who don't know,
that's my old boss there.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So
let's begin there.
We can remove our
friend from the screen.
BILL NYE: That's not
really my old boss.
It's a guy I used
to sit next to.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So my first
question is really an easy one.
You've seen the numbers.
Now, you're a science educator.
I'm a scientist.
Are those dismal
numbers a failure
of my profession or yours?
BILL NYE: Oh, it's me.
It's all me.
What's happened in the
US is the people teaching
or asked to teach science
are not especially qualified
to teach it, because the
money's just not very good.
If you come out of
engineering school
and you can get a job making
what you guys make here
or get a job making a third
of that going to a facility
where the paint's peeling
and it smells like urine
and some people literally
are carrying weapons,
what would you do?
I mean, if I were
king of the forest.
And I'm not.
But the longest journey
starts with a single step.
So our first problem is
educating science educators.
But if you have school
boards-- in other words,
we have to do
everything all at once.
If you have school boards who
are insisting that creationism
be put in textbooks, then
that's a hard row to hoe.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Yeah.
BILL NYE: But
we've got to do it.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Well,
to what extent
is this actually a uniquely
American phenomenon?
Has this happened
in other countries?
BILL NYE: Doesn't seem to.
And you can see on that
gross domestic product chart,
or handwritten graph-- no,
really, whatever you call it.
The thing.
How do we use the word "chart?"
It's a graph.
It's a depiction.
You see that industrialized
countries, in general,
believe in the
process of science,
and evolution is the main
idea in all of life science,
so they believe in that, too.
But as I say, evolution
is not something
you can choose
not to believe in.
I mean, this gets to
be sarcastic and weird.
You can choose not to believe
in gravity for a few moments.
But you'll see pretty quickly,
if you jump off a building,
you'll see right away,
you're headed for trouble.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Indeed.
BILL NYE: It's not
the fall, right?
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
It's the sudden stop.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So let's
get into the topic
of your book a little bit now.
So you wrote this book--
BILL NYE: No, I'm
really proud of it, man.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: --partly to
address that problem, I think.
But who's the audience?
Who do you want to read this--
BILL NYE: Everybody
in the whole world.
So I'll tell the story.
It's not very long,
thank goodness.
So my friends call
me Shiny Object Man.
It's a little bit of a problem.
So when you go to sit down
to write a book that's
going to have 100,000 words
or something in a row,
you have to be disciplined.
So I was looking for
an editor to help me.
And the guy I came across
through mutual acquaintances
in the business, a guy
named Corey Powell.
And he's a cool guy.
He was editor of
"Discover Magazine"
and contributes to
"Scientific American."
He also contributes
to another magazine
you may not know called
"American Scientist."
And he said, what we've
got to do is bottle,
bottle what you talk about,
and put it in a book.
And that worked out really well.
But when he was trying
to decide whether or not
to work with Shiny
Object Man over dinner,
he asked me why I
was writing the book,
because according to him-- and
when I watch other television
shows, people write
books just for the sake
of having written a book.
But he asked me, why
did you write this book?
And I told him I want
to change the world.
I want to change the world.
Is that so wrong?
And that's when he
decided to get on board.
So I wrote it for everybody.
And I wrote it in English,
as that's my native tongue.
No, I mean, really.
And I wrote it in this way that
involves me telling stories
or anecdotes or
my point of view.
And there's a reason for that.
First of all, it sounds like me,
which appeals to some people.
And then the other
thing is, I remember
the time I met Ivan the gorilla.
No, you don't.
Yeah, I do.
Yes, I do remember.
And so when you talk
about how you feel,
people can't disagree with that.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So I think
the entrenched opponents
to your worldview, which is
the evolutionary worldview,
the worldview that also
believes in gravity--
BILL NYE: Yeah.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: --they may not be
your customers for this book.
But certainly,
people like us, who
may have occasion to
persuade some of them,
can really benefit
from reading it.
BILL NYE: Well,
the other thing is
people who are anxious about
it, who are troubled by the idea
that we are all descendant
from species that
came before-- 90% of
everything that's ever lived
has disappeared-- people
who are troubled by that,
I hope they read
the book, because I
think it's empowering.
And the process of evolution
fills me with reverence.
I mean, my goodness.
Just to drop another name, I
had astronomy from Carl Sagan.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
I did.
Look, you guys, I was just some
guy in the back of the room.
"The Solar System"-- that was
the name of the course, still
is the name of course.
And I was in the
back of the room.
I did OK.
No, I did.
I was not, like,
the star student.
I did OK.
But he was the guy who
really imbued in me,
or gave me the
fundamental understanding
that, since you and I
are made of exploded
stars, the dust of exploded
stars, you and I, all of us,
are somehow at least one
way that the universe has
come to know itself.
And that is amazing.
That is amazing.
And every day, it fills
me with reverence.
And maybe more to the point,
it, like, freaks me out.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So your choice
of the word "reverence"
is interesting.
You debated, in
February, I think,
Ken Ham, the noted, or
infamous, creationist.
Did your arguments fill
him with reverence?
BILL NYE: Well, I would like
to think that I lit a spark.
And keep in mind, everybody,
that in that debate,
in that room, I was
not going to convince
Ken Ham-- how many
people saw it?
Anybody saw it?
Wow, look at you guys.
I love you, man, woman.
I was not going to change his
mind in two and a half hours.
He's made a career, he's
made quite a living,
on this idea that the
Earth is 6,000 years old.
But my audience was you
all, was people online.
And I've met many, many science
teachers the last few months
who told me that they
use the debate in class.
And that's pretty cool.
I mean, that's
reaching somebody.
So what I always
say, many of you
probably know or have family
members who are creationists,
or if they're not
creationists, they're
deeply troubled by the
idea that we are descendant
from somebody who is not human.
Even, again, on old boss joke
could be put right there.
Some people are deeply
troubled by that.
You're not going to change
their minds in one sitting.
It's a process.
So I hope this book
is part of that.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Well,
let's get into the book,
since the book began
in that debate.
Perhaps you can start by taking
us back to the 1830s, where--
BILL NYE: Ah, yes.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Not
literally, please.
BILL NYE: Vik, I wasn't there.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: No.
But you wrote about it--
BILL NYE: Yeah, yeah.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: --recently.
BILL NYE: But by the way,
Ken Ham, one of his things
is historical science and
observational science.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Yes.
BILL NYE: So if you weren't
there to observe it,
it doesn't count.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: All bets are off.
BILL NYE: Yeah.
So I'm like, dude, have you
ever seen "CSI-- Louisville?"
Or do they have that now?
They probably do.
Is there a Louisville,
Kentucky, CSI?
I think so.
I think there is.
There's so many.
I know Fargo is coming.
But you were saying--
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So that's exactly
the most interesting point.
How could Darwin, just with his
collection of observations from
a five-year voyage, without
the benefit of Illumina--
BILL NYE: DNA.
He knew nothing of DNA.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Exactly.
Yes.
How could he have come up
with such a far-ranging theory
of such predictive value?
BILL NYE: He was thoughtful.
And what's striking is, as so
many people have commented,
why didn't anybody else
think of it before?
And it shows you how
many-- or notice it
before-- how many
expectations must
be built into each of us,
how many assumptions we make
about the universe
and our relationship
to it, the cosmos
to it, that are just wrong,
and we don't even know it.
But I did tell the story,
my grandmother lived in,
looking back, a pretty big
house in Washington, DC.
It had three bedrooms,
which at that time
is a pretty big house.
And so she had boarders,
people who would rent rooms,
after my uncle and my
dad left the house.
And there was some
guy that would
sit at the dinner table
talking about chicken bones.
And "look how the knee is
just like the human knee,
but it's reversed.
And isn't this cool?
And look at this cartilage.
It's just like human cartilage."
And my grandmother, who was
quite the naturalist-- she
would collect wild
flowers; she was really
something-- thought
that was cool.
But my grandfather was somehow
deeply troubled by this.
He went to church and stuff
in a very traditional way.
But even this guy noticed
these connections.
Why didn't anybody else notice
these connections before?
It was really quite a thing.
And Darwin realized,
apparently--
I'm not an expert on
Darwin-- but he apparently
spent a lot of time making sure
he had everything worked out.
I don't know if you've ever
read "The Origin of Species
by Means of Natural Selection."
But he did all these
experiments with roses and bees
and barnacles-- he was just
really into it-- to make sure
what he was observing, his
hypothesis, was correct.
And then this guy Russel
Wallace-- and there's
a whole bunch of people, and
I'm right there with you,
who celebrate Russel Wallace,
as he came up with the same idea
at the same time.
And why isn't there a
Russel Wallace Society,
and when will we have
Russel Wallace day,
and why isn't Russell
Wallace on our dollar bills?
OK.
He was 16 years
younger than Darwin.
Darwin had a little
head start on him.
And Darwin's book, where
he's got both the hypothesis,
or the theory, of evolution
and the experiments
backing it up in one volume.
That's way Darwin's name
is so closely tied--
VIKRAM BAJAJ: And it's a very
accessible book even today.
BILL NYE: Yeah.
Even now, it's very readable.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Well, why
isn't Darwin on any currency?
BILL NYE: Well,
he is in Britain.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Is he?
BILL NYE: Darwin's on
dollar-- on dollar bills--
on bills in Britain.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Oh, interesting.
So can you take us
through some of the more
contemporary evidence
for Darwin's theories?
Let's start with geology
and the fossil record.
I know you do this
very well in the book.
BILL NYE: Well, you guys, I went
to school in Ithaca, New York.
And you can walk
around in Ithaca--
you don't have to be any
sort of amazing geology guy--
and you can find trilobite
fossils, zillions of them.
Trilobites lived something
like 238 million years--
way longer than humans have been
on Earth by a factor of 100,
I guess-- factor of 100,
not 100, a factor of 100.
And so you find
all those fossils.
Well, how'd they all get
there, for crying out loud?
And then Darwin
wrestled with this.
And how does a new species
come into existence?
And it's just a cool story.
I don't know if you know about
the mosquitoes in the London
Underground, the Tube.
So apparently, the mosquitoes
were living in the underground
when they dug all these
tunnels in the late 1800s.
There were mosquitoes
living down there.
And they would feed on
people like you and me.
And they would generally-- I
mean, if you're a mosquito,
you feed on a few people, and
then they close the subway, you
go back upstairs at night and
feed on some other people.
But then, when World
War II came along,
they used the underground
stations as bomb shelters.
And it's quite effective.
I mean, getting
bombed kind of sucks.
But it was quite effective.
But this really accelerated
the certain mosquitoes.
Pipiens has become molestus.
The mosquitoes that
buzzes, pipien,
has become the
mosquito that annoys.
So there's apparently
a new species
of mosquito evolving in the
London Underground right now.
And furthermore, you
can see the spectrum.
Most of the underground
mosquitoes cannot breed with
the above grounds.
So the pipiens cannot
breed with the molestus.
But there are a
few that still can.
Like you can see that there's
a spectrum of this new species
coming into existence,
like in real time,
like in one person's lifetime.
And that's amazing.
That's amazing.
It's not surprising,
really, but it's amazing.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So what connects
these contemporary examples
of speciation-- and there
are a couple that you go over
in your book,
including evolution
of antibiotic resistance
and other things short
of speciation--
what connects that
with this historical
fossil record?
Is it DNA evidence?
How do you know how
old the fossils are?
BILL NYE: Oh, I see.
Well, yeah, how many people
have not taken geology?
I don't know you guys.
I don't know how you live.
I don't know anything
about your habits.
But you'll find that the older
dirty clothes that you've
discarded on the floor are
underneath the more recent
dirty clothes.
And the same is true in geology
with respect to sediments
and overlays and so on.
And I'm not the world's
foremost geologist,
but I can tell you the stuff
at the bottom of the Grand
Canyon's older than
the stuff at the top.
I don't make the
rules, as we say.
The other just amazing thing
that was sort of discovered,
really, in my father's lifetime,
my grandfather's lifetime,
is radioactivity and how
you can work backwards.
And people throw out the
word "carbon dating."
Carbon dating, it's
fine, but that's not
what we're talking about.
Carbon dating is good on, like,
tens of thousands of years.
Radiometric dating,
where you have-- I mean,
who doesn't love
rubidium and strontium?
These are elements
that are out there.
And they're radioactive.
And I like that
one in many ways.
First of all, its half-life
of rubidium becoming strontium
is 48.8 billion years--
b-- billion years.
And it's a case where one
of the neutrons in rubidium
becomes a proton.
It goes up the periodic table,
giving off some electrons
and neutrinos.
Who wouldn't?
And so then these
things are chemically
in the same column on the
periodic table as calcium
and sodium so that, in
the melt, as these guys
love-- who doesn't
love the melt?
The melt-- you're talking
about molten rocks.
You're talking about
Hawaii or someplace.
These things are all mixed in.
But once they freeze,
once it cools off,
then, chemically,
some of the rubidium,
some of the
strontium, is replaced
by some of the sodium,
some of the calcium.
And then you can work
this clock backwards.
This is amazing, It's amazing.
And that was discovered
long after Darwin's writing
this book.
I mean, it's just cool.
Just think what else
we just don't know
anything about, right
under our noses.
Wow.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Of course,
to believe in that, you
have to believe in--
BILL NYE: Everything.
VIKRAM BAJAJ:
--the inviolability
of physical laws, which,
as we saw in your debate,
that's not always been the case.
BILL NYE: Yeah.
So one of the
extraordinary claims
this guy makes,
these people make,
is that physical
laws are mutable,
you can just change them.
Super-guy shows up and
goes, the speed of light,
I'm going to quintuple it for
awhile, without telling anyone.
It's unreasonable.
And this wouldn't
matter, Vik, would not
matter-- this guy can spend
his millions of dollars
and build his thing and
run around doing his stuff.
But they have this
enormous program
to indoctrinate kids,
people in kindergarten,
that the Earth is
6,000 years old
and all these things on how
to defend your otherwise
completely unreasonable
belief and so on.
And that's what's
really troubling.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: I agree.
So tell us a bit-- and you
outlined this in your book
in greater detail-- about the
parallel line of evidence from
modern DNA sequencing methods
that also establishes--
BILL NYE: Oh, yeah.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: --age of life.
BILL NYE: It's amazing.
So you guys, there's mutations
that happen natural-- I mean,
every time you try
to make a copy,
there's going to be a change.
Sometimes, the change
is significant.
Most of the time, it's not.
It's just in the-- what
do you guys call it?
Healthy software?
Healthy code.
Healthy coding.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Ah, yes.
BILL NYE: Yeah, where you just
leave old code in the thing
because you don't
want to mess with it.
Then it turns out there's
some bug in there-- bah!
Smoke comes out.
Yeah, so there's apparently
a lot of leftover DNA
that doesn't do--
we can't figure out
what it does right now.
It doesn't seem to
make any change.
But there are very
significant changes.
These things happen
regularly, like a clock.
So you can assess the speed
at which DNA is changing,
and then you can work back to
when the Neanderthals and us
were apparently hunting the
same game and interacting.
Can we say "interacting" here?
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Yes.
In fact, you need not
use the euphemism.
But--
BILL NYE: They were doing it.
They were jumping each other.
They were having sex.
They had sexual intercourse.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So
actually, that--
BILL NYE: Interaction.
That whole interact
culture that's emerged now.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: It brings
me to my next question.
And it's an important
topic in evolution.
I think you spend the
majority of the book on this.
So I'd like to read
from one chapter.
BILL NYE: Oh, I love you.
He's reading.
No, that's worthy.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: The
chapter's called
"My Prom and Sexual Selection."
So it begins, "Being
a nerd, I did not
anticipate going to
my high school prom."
BILL NYE: It's true.
VIKRAM BAJAJ:
"Nevertheless, I did.
I was driven to
do so, apparently,
by the shape of Leith's legs"--
BILL NYE: Leith.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Leith.
Excuse me.
--"a clearly female classmate.
This fascination with sex
is, near as anyone can tell,
not something we get to choose.
Our ancestors
bequeathed it to us.
It is another one of those
deeply shared evolutionary
traits, a drive that
we cannot disengage."
So what's the role of sexual
reproduction in evolution?
BILL NYE: That's an old mystery.
But we have an excellent theory
as to why sex is so popular.
[LAUGHTER]
And not just among people.
Dandelions and sea
jellies, barnacles, they're
all doing it like
crazy out there.
And so it's complicated.
You know, one of the
things I often reflect on,
it's "The lilies of the
field, they do not toil,
nor do they sow."
They don't do anything.
Actually, if you're a lily,
you are busting your empennage
to make flowers.
All the energy you put into
making ova, eggs and pollen,
it's a tremendous
amount of work.
And the reason it's
done, apparently,
is because of parasites.
So if you're a meta
multicellular organism,
like us, your enemy,
in general, is not
a lion, a tiger, or a bear.
Those, of course, are trouble,
as well documented in the film.
But your main problem
is germs and parasites.
So germs, if they're bacteria,
they're reproducing like crazy.
They double in just a few hours.
You'll have-- unchecked--
enormous populations of germs.
But us, it takes us months.
And after all the negotiation,
the going out to dinner,
and all that stuff-- no,
it takes a long time.
And then, when the kid's born,
you're looking at nothing.
You've got years more
on top of that, right?
So apparently, sex
is a way to come up
with a new combination of genes
that the germs, parasites, just
can't quite keep up with.
And this is charmingly referred
to as the theory of the Red
Queen.
But the guy was British,
so the Red Queen.
Alice of "Alice
in Wonderland" is
in "Through the Looking
Glass," the second book.
And she meets the Red Queen,
who's-- from my understanding,
Lewis Carroll, I don't
know if he smoked dope,
but he probably did.
And so the Red Queen is like
this chess piece person.
And she's sliding around
on the chessboard of life.
And so when you're
talking to her,
you have to run all the time.
But it's not explained
about the queen's legs
or her felt bottom,
whatever chess pieces have.
And so Alice says, "You
know, where I come from,
if you run all day, you'll
end up somewhere else."
And the queen says,
"Well, that seems
like a very slow
sort of country."
And so this is the
idea of evolution.
If you stop running, you will
fall off the treadmill of life.
You will disappear.
So this having sex, new
combination of genes,
new combination of genes,
is how you stay in the game.
And the predictive quality of
the theory of evolution just
really comes into play.
And I mentioned
this in Kentucky,
and I mention it
again in the book.
These crazy fish--
VIKRAM BAJAJ: The minnows.
BILL NYE: --in Mexico--
the top minnows
is how we say it in English--
when there are not enough mates
around, they just become
what Darwin called asexual.
But we might call
it double-sexual.
They just start reproducing
without doing it.
And then those
reproduced fish are
more susceptible to parasites.
But then, when it
rains again and there's
a whole bunch of ponds
to swim around in
and the fish population
gets big again,
then they go back to
sexual reproduction.
Crazy.
Humans don't do that.
I mean, a lot is said
about it nowadays,
but humans don't do that.
It's not the thing.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: There's actually
one aspect of human sexuality,
I think, that you
don't touch upon--
BILL NYE: What?
VIKRAM BAJAJ: --in the book.
Just one.
BILL NYE: Because
it fascinates me.
Yeah.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: And of course,
for thousands of years,
we've known that same-sex
relationships are
perfectly normal, documented.
And there's an increasing
body of literature
which suggests some
genetic causes, as well
as epigenetic causes.
BILL NYE: Oh, yeah.
Oh, absolutely.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So what's the
evolutionary theoretical
thinking on homosexuality?
BILL NYE: Well, I'm
not an expert on this.
But I can tell you-- and
the word people throw around
nowadays, it's a spectrum.
I think being a homosexual
guy is clearly not
genetically lethal.
Homosexual guys have babies,
have kids, all the time.
And so there's some blur.
And also, my understanding--
I'm not an expert on this--
but apparently, it's a
very common-- people always
presume that human
female sexuality
is more fluid than
male sexuality.
But apparently, human
male homosexuals often
have a period of having
a crush or a thing
for a woman, a female human.
So it must be-- because
it doesn't kill you,
because it doesn't keep
you from having babies,
it's still out there.
Or it's out there.
Or it's out there-- it's
always been out there.
But I'm not an expert on that.
And I'm telling you there's
an evolutionary reason for it.
There's got to be.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Absolutely.
BILL NYE: It's got to be
consistent with the theory
of evolution, whatever
it turns out to be.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: There have
been some papers and articles
recently on the subject relating
to kin selection and altruism,
which are some of the
counterintuitive aspects
of evolutionary theory.
Maybe we could get
into those now.
BILL NYE: At first.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: At first, yes.
So proponents of
creationism, they often
claim that there is no altruism
in the evolutionary model.
Perhaps you can
explain how that's--
BILL NYE: Oh, without them.
Without the religion,
there'd be no altruism.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Yes.
BILL NYE: Yeah.
No, apparently, altruism
is-- for those of you--
it's a word not
everybody uses all
the time-- the drive to
help somebody else out,
to help out another
member of your species.
And the example that I just
am charmed by are the bats.
Did anybody see the
Bill Nye caves show?
That was a great one.
It was really good.
It was later on,
and we had a budget.
And so we flew to Carlsbad
Cavern in New Mexico.
And it was just cool.
But we were able to be
right there with the bats.
And there are a lot
of bats, you guys.
So apparently, the bats go out,
they eat mosquitoes all night.
Not everybody is a good
mosquito hunter, bat-wise.
And so if a bat comes
back to the roost
and has not had enough to
eat, one of the other bats
will, out of courtesy,
barf up some mosquito barf
and feed the other guy.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Interesting.
BILL NYE: Now, why
would they do that?
And as I say in the
book, that hungry bat
should not have been
wearing those headphones
and listening to that
rock 'n' roll music.
He should've been echolocating
and eating mosquitoes
at very high speed and so on.
But why do they do that?
Well, apparently,
it's to preserve
their tribe, their
roost, their rookery.
And it's a heck of a thing.
And I talk about humans.
You guys can do this
thought experiment.
And it's an experiment, OK?
I mean, it's a game.
It's a game theory.
It's creepy.
House is on fire, you're only
allowed to save one person.
That's a rule.
Do you save your
mother or-- let's
see, let me just--
hang on-- do you save
your grandmother, your
mother, or your own kid?
And you save your own
kid, because you're
driven to reach as far into
the genetic future as possible.
With that said, humans are
always helping out other humans
without nearly that close
of a genetic connection.
You remember when this
building was burning in Texas
and this construction
worker was there
and they got the fire truck
ladder right up to it,
and the guy jumped
off-- whoa-- and then
the building
collapsed-- [WHOOSH].
And nobody said, well he
should he have done that?
That was very dangerous.
No.
It's what humans do.
We just help out other humans.
And apparently,
that's deep within us.
And I don't want to
cause no trouble.
But that seems to
be deeper within us
and older than the
invention or discovery
or whatever the expression
is of religions.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Sure.
BILL NYE: So it's not clear
the cause and effect there.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Absolutely.
So perhaps we can go over
one or two other really
counterintuitive
aspects of evolution.
So one that you describe--
BILL NYE: God, you
read the book, Vik.
I love you, man.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: I did.
BILL NYE: No, a lot of times,
you get interviewed by people,
and the majority didn't
actually read the book
because they've got stuff to do.
And they just look at
the chapter titles.
Go ahead.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So biodiversity.
BILL NYE: Biodiversity.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Yeah, how does it
fit into evolutionary theory?
BILL NYE: Well, it is reasonable
that the longer life has
been in any one place, the
more diverse it becomes.
The longer species have been
generating, interacting,
with humans in the
subway or what have you,
the more species you get.
And not surprisingly,
where there's
the most sunlight, the
most energy coming in
from outer space, that's
where the most diversity is,
at the equator, or
near the equator.
In tropical rainforests is where
you have the most diversity.
Then, as you go north or
south from the equator,
there's less diversity.
With that said, it
doesn't mean that there
are fewer individuals.
If you've ever flown over the
forest in Canada or Pacific
Northwest, there's just trees
and trees and trees and trees.
But there's actually
less diversity
of trees, less different
types of plants and animals
there, than in the Amazon.
And that's absolutely
consistent with the way
species come to be.
It's what you'd expect.
Now, one of the great
mysteries right now--
and you guys may be alive when
this is figured out-- well,
of course, the fundamental
mystery is how did it all gets
started.
Like, where did
we come from, man?
Like, dude.
And I talk about this all the
time with the planetary side.
Where did we come
from, and are we alone?
Those are the deep,
deep questions.
But it's very reasonable that
life started in the deep sea,
in one of these hydrothermal
vents, where there's
all this hot water and
salt and nutrients--
I mean hot water and
nutrients and heat.
I guess hot water would
have heat, wouldn't it?
OK, thank you, Bill.
Or did it start on land
with lightning strikes
from a scraping atmosphere
on the Earth's surface
and roiling?
I tell the story, I walked
into-- at Cornell University--
I went to Cornell, you guys.
Don't bust their chops.
Go, Big Red.
But I'm sure it was a
mistake on their part.
They did not intend to let me.
Once I was there, they
were kind of stuck.
But there's a whole
building called
Space Sciences, made
of cinder block.
It's not a great
looking building.
But on the third floor,
I walked in one day
on the Urey-Miller experiment.
Now, I was a mechanical-- I
still am-- mechanical engineer.
I have a license, people.
But I walked in there.
And if you've never
heard of this thing,
the Urey-Miller experiment
is where these guys
tried to reproduce the
primordial atmosphere
of the Earth and then
spark it with lightning
to see if anything would happen.
And indeed, they got
one zillion amino acids,
carbon with oxygen-oxygen on it.
And so I went, wow,
that's evidence of life.
Wow, it could be, but
it's not quite alive.
And so these questions go
back, where'd we all come from?
So did it start on
the surface, or did it
start on the deep ocean?
Maybe you guys will
figure that out.
Doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo.
VIKRAM BAJAJ:
Actually, I do want
to discuss the work of
your planetary society.
Let me--
BILL NYE: I love you, man.
VIKRAM BAJAJ:
--introduce that again.
I think it's a natural correlate
of evolutionary thinking.
So you write, at the
end of your book,
"At the end of the
journey of this book,
I find myself thinking about
the end journey of evolution
itself, not just
human evolution,
but the process as a whole.
I have long wondered
whether there
is some kind of cosmic
imperative for life
to spread from world to world.
On Earth, we see that organisms
colonize every possible niche.
We see that living things
move into new environments
and beget new species.
Is life destined to colonize
the solar system, the Milky Way,
and ultimately to spread out
through the whole universe?"
So you don't answer
the question.
BILL NYE: I don't know, man.
So you guys were
living at a time
where-- so you guys are all big,
successful engineers, right?
When I left, it was Fortran 7.
When I went to school,
we had punch cards.
And I had a slide
rule. [COUGHING]
And that's not
the good old days.
But where would you
be working if you
weren't working at Google?
SpaceX, right?
You want to work at SpaceX.
I know, I know, I know.
But I just tell everybody--
do you guys know
the motto of the
state of California?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Eureka.
BILL NYE: Eureka.
Yeah.
Eureka-- I found it.
And so these European
people come over the hill.
And there are salmon in the
Sacramento River, like this.
I mean, it's all the
protein you'd ever want.
Apparently, the first
American, first nation people
from the Pacific
Northwest are generally,
by archaeologists,
considered the richest people
in the Americas, because
they had all these salmon.
They had just infinite protein.
So they could just mess
around with other projects.
But these guys
come over the hill,
and orange trees are like weeds.
And then, at one
point in California,
the rocks are made of gold.
Like the rocks are gold.
We still have the San Francisco
49ers, for crying out loud.
But when you go to Mars, you
guys, it ain't like that.
I'm sorry.
It's hostile.
It's freezing cold.
There is no liquid water.
And when you open the
door of the spaceship,
you will find out right
away, you cannot breathe.
You will notice that.
And so I want to go to Mars,
but I want to come back.
I want to go look for
signs of life on Mars.
Yes, yes, yes.
If we discovered life on
another world in our lifetime,
it would utterly, utterly
change this world.
It would change
the way everybody
thinks about everything.
And we can do it, you
guys, for $2 billion.
Let's go.
We can go out there
and have a look.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Let's talk
about Mars a little bit more.
There's flowing water on Mars.
There's, perhaps, good
reason to believe that life,
maybe even as we know
it, existed there.
How would you find it?
BILL NYE: So a couple things.
I mean, don't get me wrong.
My father was quite
the rock hound.
You know this expression
"some of my best friends."
Some of my best friends
are geologists, really.
And I love rocks.
Every rock tells a story.
But what we're doing right now,
we spend about $1.5 billion
a year on planetary science.
Now, to put that in
perspective, the NASA budget
is $17.7 billion a year.
And if you ask people
on the street, what
percentage of the US federal
budget is the NASA budget,
somebody'll say, 10%.
It's 0.4%.
So $1.5 billion is 9% of 0.4%.
And if we were to just up that a
little so that-- the expression
that these guys love is
the landing ellipse-- so
that the spacecraft could
be targeted to Mars more
accurately, then-- whoa--
then 60-kilometer-long-- whoa,
that's pretty close.
Let me tell you guys, if you're
looking for something to eat
and you're off by 60 kilometers,
you're going to be hungry.
So what if we spent
more money and tightened
that up and then made these
cool, extraordinary robots that
could repel, in rock
climber fashion,
down the side of a hill on Mars
and get where there might be
super salty slushy water
on a Martian summer day,
and then maybe you'd
find fossil microbes?
But wait, maybe there'd
be something still alive.
Bahahaha.
And we could do that,
you know, $1.8 billion
a year for 10 or 12 years.
We could do that.
We just have to be motivated.
And let alone if we spend
Apollo kind of money on it,
we could get 'er done.
And it would change
the freaking world.
It would absolutely
change the world.
And this is the
romance of it for me.
And we are uniquely
qualified to do this.
Well, we should be
paying teacher salaries,
and we should be-- yes.
If you're a politician,
the problem is not,
should we pay teachers,
should we go to Mars?
We have to do it all.
And the other thing I'd
just remind you guys--
and I know we're in New York.
We're all a bunch of
progressive, bleeding heart,
liberal, crazy people--
but remind you guys
that when you invest in
space exploration especially,
the return on it
is extraordinary.
You guys would not have jobs
without the space program.
The internet would not exist
without the US space program.
And then you talk about all
the materials-- everybody
loves his Teflon and
this Velcro and stuff.
But it's the
expectation that you
can get things done
in a big way, that's
what the space
exploration brings to us.
So that's why I advocate
for it right now.
And then, along that line,
I'd just remind everybody
that climate change, in
the modern era-- I mean,
it was discovered in the
19th century, really.
And Benjamin Franklin
speculated about it.
But in the modern
era, climate change
was discovered, really, on
Venus, the planet Venus.
And so space exploration just
brings out the best in us.
And that's why--
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Including Carl
Sagan and others, Jim Hansen.
BILL NYE: Well,
Carl Sagan-- so I
like to say-- yeah, James
Hansen-- the computer models
that we use even today
for climate modeling
are based, really, on the
original ones from the 1970s.
And right around
the year 1980 is
when people really-- where
you guys even freaking
born in 1980?
I suck.
It was right there where
disco was giving way
to punk and new wave and
the important work of Sid
Vicious and the Sex Pistols.
Sorry, I don't get it.
I never got it.
Not my thing.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So the
subject is actually
related to some of the questions
that the audience is raising.
BILL NYE: Oh, here
we are, tweeting.
That's how we roll.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: It's
our version of that.
BILL NYE: Oh, sorry, sorry.
My bad.
Ooh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're geeking.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Whose name
I forget, I must admit.
So we don't have
an Apollo program.
Some of us who grew
up in the '80s,
we were nevertheless motivated
by space exploration,
human space flight.
Now we're faced with really
existential problems, where
science is the only solution.
But there's nothing
really to motivate
people to go into science as--
BILL NYE: Well, that's
our job here at Google.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: What's
the role for Google,
and what's the role for
big government science?
BILL NYE: OK.
I have an issue now.
There are people
in elected office
who feel that government is bad.
Like, why did you
take this gig, man?
They feel that
government should be
shrunk as much as
possible and destroyed.
As that guy, the anti-tax
guy, says, to put in a bathtub
and drown.
I just really
disagree with that.
The New York City subway takes
a billion passengers a year.
You absolutely could not do
that in the libertarian society.
You just couldn't.
Sorry, man.
And I don't want
two sets of sewers,
two sets of phone lines,
two sets of cell towers.
Phone lines, sorry,
older reference.
Sorry.
I don't know if you
knew this, but there
used to be copper wires
that transmitted voice.
It was OK.
Not much bandwidth.
It was all right.
It was a long time ago.
It was more than
two years ago, yeah.
They're still in the '10s,
the 2010s, 20 aughts.
So one of the
things about climate
change that is something
for everybody to consider,
people who are against
government intrusion,
government getting
into your business,
I think they're really going
to be troubled by what's
going to be required to
address climate change.
And the model for this is in
my parents' day, World War II.
You couldn't just buy
tires for your car.
You couldn't just buy meat.
You couldn't buy
certain vegetables,
especially at
certain times a year.
You just couldn't.
They weren't available, because
the man stepped in and sent it
to the boys to conduct the war.
And that was government
intrusion in a way
that-- people talk about
the greatest generation.
Part of the reason that
people considered it great
is because they worked together.
And to address
climate change, it's
going to be that same deal.
The sooner we get started,
the better, for me.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: And what role
do you see, more specifically,
for large corporations,
like Google?
BILL NYE: Like Google?
Man.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: What
do you want us to do?
BILL NYE: No, the
key to the future,
kids, peoples, you are it.
You are IT.
Wait.
No.
No, you are it, because
the key to the future
is not just to do less.
I grew up-- I'm so old-- I
remember the very first Earth
Day.
The very first Earth Day was
in 1970, before Motown really
was called Motown.
The Motor City existed, but
the music, although it existed,
didn't have that sobriquet.
Anyway-- digress, me?
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Or perhaps
there's no easy answer.
BILL NYE: No, no.
So in those days, everybody
wanted you to do less,
to drive your car less,
to use less clean water,
so wear dirty clothes.
And humans are bad.
Humans don't belong
in the ecosystem,
humans have nothing to do with
nature, get rid of humans.
In fact, if you
can, just don't eat.
Don't even eat, really.
And that's turned
out to be, as you
might imagine, not
especially popular.
And so the key to the
future is not to do less.
The key is to do more with less.
And that's where
companies like Google
enable this in an amazing way.
Do you know how many
hours people my age
spent in the freaking library?
I mean, going to look
things up in a card catalog
was a skill you developed.
But the difference was,
when you found stuff
in the encyclopedia--
if you found
the atomic number
of strontium-- 38--
in the Encyclopedia
Britannica, it
was almost certainly correct.
There was no issue with that.
Whereas now, when you
look on Wikipedia,
you just don't know what
you're going to get.
So it's a new skill that
students have to develop,
is how to sift through this
greater volume of lower quality
information.
But the world will be better,
because not everybody has
to get in the car or
the subway to commute.
People can commute
from their phone.
The planetary side,
people are extraordinarily
productive without ever coming
into the office, I have to say.
But that doesn't
mean I don't want
you coming into the
office, you guys.
I'm sorry, if you're out there.
And so Google is a key
to doing more with less.
But somewhere along
the line, you guys,
somebody's going to have
to make electricity.
You can have all the
server farms you want,
but if you can't plug them
in, we're in bad shape.
And this is when-- is
it true that robots
are going to take
over the world?
I mean, if somebody keeps
shoveling coal for them,
I guess.
But if you stop
making electricity,
the robots will really have
a hard time of it, generally.
No, they'll make
nuclear power plants.
OK, all right, maybe.
It's not so simple.
So go ahead.
Sorry.
Hold it.
It says right here, we're
not going to do any-- whoa,
I've blown it.
Sorry.
Go ahead.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So there
is really no easy answer.
It's something that we
all have to struggle to--
BILL NYE: Well, when it comes to
climate change, in my opinion,
the answer is to do everything
we possibly can, all at once.
How's that?
More efficient electricity,
more efficient trans--
transportation is a
huge cost, especially
in the US-- more efficient
cities, more efficient farms,
in the biggest picture,
and of course, raising
the quality of life,
especially of women and girls,
because deep within
this problem--
when I was here at the
World's Fair, in 1965,
I was nine years old,
the world had just
gotten 3 billion people.
Well, a few days ago, I checked.
We're at 7.2 billion people.
And that's it.
You've more than doubled
the number of humans
burning and breathing the
atmosphere in the last two
decades.
That's your problem.
So we need to reduce
the human population.
We do.
But I mean, this is--
you guys, we don't do it.
By the way, war is
completely ineffective.
Ebola will not do it.
No.
And you can see it historically.
The scale of the
problem is huge.
Well, if you raise the standard
of living of women and girls,
over the next
century and a half,
the human population will
stabilize and go down.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: Sure.
BILL NYE: And the way to do that
is to educate women and girls.
This is a really huge problem.
But let's get going, people.
We can change the world.
AUDIENCE: Whoo, yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL NYE: Thanks, you guys.
I love you guys.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: So we don't have
time for audience questions,
for live questions.
But there was one last
question that I wanted to--
BILL NYE: The dead questions
are very troubling.
Yeah.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: There's one
last question from the screen
that I wanted to
discuss with you.
It's really, again, on
the subject of evolution.
How can individuals debate
their family members, others,
who are creationists
or who don't
understand evolutionary theory?
BILL NYE: So you guys,
that is your job.
People ask me-- I see a few
of these questions-- what's
the most important
thing you could do?
What's a single-- if
you had to do one thing,
what would you do?
Who's the target audience--
[INTENTIONALLY MUMBLES]
Oh, I see the Higgs boson.
Let me just say, you
guys, I'm not so sure.
5 sigma is good.
But it ain't 9 sigma.
It ain't 7 sigma.
I've said it, OK?
I've said it.
I believe in 5 sigma,
but compare a Toyota
to a Detroit car.
Toyota designs at 5 sigma,
Detroit designs at 3.
Compare and contrast.
VIKRAM BAJAJ: There may have
to be some retractions now.
BILL NYE: No, I'm just saying.
So the single most
important thing
we can all do right
now, I believe,
is talk about climate change.
Just raise awareness.
Just make it part of our
everyday conversation,
because we are all living
in a little bit of denial
of climate change.
And I'm the first
to say, me too.
I, as well.
Mea culpa.
By raising awareness
of climate change,
we will get something done.
Now, just by way
of example, my dad
took a job in 1941
on Wake Island.
I don't know if you've
ever heard of it.
You go to Hawaii, and
then you go about that
far again to Wake.
It's still a tactically
important place.
There are about 700 US Air Force
landings, airplane landings,
every year.
When you went to
Asia, in the old days,
you'd fly from San Francisco
to Pearl Harbor to Wake
and then on to Midway,
usually, in Shanghai, in China.
But without Wake Island,
you couldn't make that trip.
Anyway, everybody thought,
well, things are going to be OK.
There's never going to
be a war in the Pacific.
World War II is never
going to come to the US.
Everything's going to be fine.
And my dad took that job, and
then he ended up in prison camp
for four years.
And so I don't recommend
that, by the way.
But people in the US, just
looking at it historically--
and this new movie came out
about Turing, Alan Turing,
and everything-- people
thought the problem is so big,
it won't happen.
And I think we're all doing that
with respect to climate change.
So talk about it.
Talk about climate change.
Talk about evolution.
Get in fights over the Isaac
Newton's birthday holiday
Christmas table.
Isaac Newton was born
on Christmas day,
by the way, as
reckoned in Britain.
In Italy, it was the
fourth of January.
They were still not
agreeing on the calendar.
But I always say,
Isaac Newton's mom
thought it was Christmas
day, for crying out loud.
So you guys, just talk
about climate change.
And then, together,
I strongly believe,
as I look at history and
the greatest generation
and what have you,
we can do this.
We can change the world.
So thank you all so much.
Thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]